At this juncture, you should have had enough time to go in, add all of your various different
lights, add your kicker lights, change your colorations, right?
Essentially build out the scene that you want and you want to achieve.
And now we're going to start getting into adding back in some of those artistic effects
that we removed with our neutralized scene.
So if you recall, when we set up our scene, we created a neutral baseline, right?
We removed any of the post-processing effects, anything like bloom, et cetera.
Well now we can go in and actually add these back into our scene.
And through that, we're actually going to use a process that I really like, which is
just called layered post-processing.
So rather than go back into our post-processing volume that we first set up, we can keep it
there.
In fact, we can just add a secondary post-processing volume and start overriding some of those
various different settings that we want to bring back.
Now the key here is our priority.
So if you recall, inside of our post-processing volume settings where we set the infinite
extent unbound or enabled or disabled, we can also give that post-processing volume
a priority.
Now the higher the priority, right?
So one is higher than zero means that that post-processing volume, any setting that we
check will override whatever is below it.
So let's jump back into our scene real quick.
And if you want to start on this one, we can just go to content, classrooms, walkthrough,
and we'll start on the post-processing volume.
Now just a quick note, feel free to dissect this entire scene.
Now this is obviously outside of the time that we have for this particular training
module, these videos.
But in here you'll see that I've used all of the various different techniques that we've
covered in the previous videos.
So here are overhead lights.
Here you can see that three-point lighting we set up.
In fact, I added a fourth for kind of a nice little fill on the bumper.
And then we've also added our kicker lights on the inside here.
So again, feel free to select the lights and you can go through the various different settings
that I use to achieve this.
And then lastly, while we didn't cover how to use spotlights, essentially the principles
are exact same.
We can go to our place actors, drag in a spotlight.
In particular, the difference between a spotlight and say a rec light or a point light is we
actually have a cone.
So in this case, I've added two spotlights onto the logo because why would it be a car
commercial if we didn't have our logo?
So here you can see that I'm adding just a little splash of light to the logo.
So from whatever direction the vehicle is being viewed, very prominent here on the front.
So we turn it off, on, off on.
Same principle here as the kickers on the inside.
We're simply just adding some accent lighting to our scene.
All right.
So that should bring us to where we're at.
Okay.
So now what we want to do is go in and actually add some post-processing effects back to our
scene.
So then I'm going to go back to my place actors and just search for post-processing volume,
drag this into our scene.
And again, this doesn't necessarily matter where we place it.
I'm going to go ahead and reset it to zero.
I'll select off of it, select it again so it should highlight within.
I'll go ahead and just roll up some of these things in our.
There we go.
So underneath environment, we have our PPV neutral and here is our new post-processing.
So I'm just going to rename this to PPV and then we can call this artistic.
And again, this is just going to be all of our artistic settings that we want to override.
So I'll go ahead and drag this up to environment just to stay nice, neat and tidy.
So with my post-processing volume, the artistic one selected, I'm going to scroll down, do
our same thing, make sure infinite extent unbound is checked.
And then again, we just want to make sure that the priority is higher than whatever
our baseline is, which if we select the neutral, you'll see we set it.
We're set at zero.
So my artistic, I'm going to set at one.
And basically just to show the way this works is right now I have a bunch of various different
settings, but you'll notice that nothing really changed within our scene and nothing will
change until we actually go in and adjust one of those parameters.
So for just ease of viewing what's happening here, I'm going to check my exposure compensation.
And if you recall from our neutral, it's set to negative 5.5.
So as soon as I uncheck this, whatever is below it, so whatever the next presiding value
is, which in this case is 5.5 from a neutral, that's what will take effect.
But by checking it, now I have the ability to override that value.
So I'll go ahead and just reset it and uncheck it.
All right.
So now again, I'm going to press G just to go into game mode so you can see it's happening.
This is where we can go in and start adding our artistic effects back in.
All right.
So I could turn on bloom again.
So we get that nice bloom.
We can adjust our threshold.
I could take my intensity.
Right.
We could do whatever it is that we wanted to.
We could also go into different lens flares.
We could change various different vignettes, do something like this.
We can even go as far as actually doing color grading within the editor itself.
So I could go something like my temperature, so I could tint it, maybe do something ultra
warm or maybe we drop it down.
I could tint the effect as well.
I can even go into my various different highlights and shadows.
So maybe on my shadows, I want to bump up the gain a little bit, or maybe I want to
make it really noir-esque.
Whatever you decide that you want to do.
At any point, I can just disable these and again, retain whatever is below it.
Okay.
All right.
So once you go through and you add all these different settings, again, the important part
to keep in mind here is we haven't lost our calibrated baseline effect.
All I have to do with my artistic is either hide it or I could simply just go down into
the post-processing volume settings and just disable it.
And now we're back to our neutralized baseline.
But of course, if I disable both, you'll see now this is just the engine doing its thing.
There's auto exposure in place.
So by having both of these on there, that allows us to achieve whatever artistic look
that we want to and still maintain that neutralized baseline.